failure doesn't mean you've failed
failure gives us an opportunity to
to get it right welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance touring
opposed labs and hillel at stanford this
show is about the journey of leaders
and this episode embodies exactly that
meet michelle taylor willis the founder
of gagnint media
michelle taylor willis is the founder of
gagnet media a florida native she is
married with four sons and resides in
atlanta georgia
she is a proud graduate of the
university of florida and an
award-winning entrepreneur
author speaker and master strategist
michelle recently launched her first
book
raising significance a guide to
well-rounded independent and confident
kids
she has appeared on the nationally
syndicated tamron hall show on abc
to discuss the book and on the fox
affiliate in atlanta
as well as being featured in several
publications michelle taylor willis
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
hey i am doing great thanks for having
me michael i love your name i think we
have the same name
there you go uh where am i catching you
in the world right now where are you
well i am in atlanta georgia in atlanta
georgia well i i haven't had the chance
to visit atlanta georgia so
i i'm definitely adding that to my
bucket list
but michelle you got it
i i definitely want to give me one thing
that i that i'll experience when i
arrive at atlanta georgia that i must
experience
me there you go you i see i i had a
feeling i was gonna be the answer i i
love it
michelle you're a storyteller you are
um you know if the journey that you've
done i i don't even know how to
categorize you because you've done so
many different things
the work that you're doing now you know
exemplifies such a unique
and an amazing journey throughout the
years
both the impact that you have on people
and the insights you have young
entrepreneurs the book that is that is
coming out and you know just the
different things that you've learned
over your career so what i'd love to do
if it's okay with you just to go all the
way back to you studying
marketing and advertising and you're
starting the telecom industry
and walk me through some of the big
milestones you've done to get to where
you are today and then we'll pick and
choose
some fun lessons to talk about okay
um so let me just start off by saying
i'm a salesperson i
i i started selling when i was
15. actually i probably started selling
when i was like one
but uh but my first job selling was when
i was 15 years old
and i got to tell you that my my whole
trajectory traject trajectory in life
has been built on my career as a sales
person
right when i was formally in sales for
corporate america
and then as a salesperson for my own
business
right um everybody's in sales and i
learned that at the age of 15.
so my career started um
in an insurance agency where i was
dating
this guy and his mom and insurance
agency and she hired me to cold call
and so i literally would come in
every tuesday and thursday from like
seven to nine pm
because at that point that time that was
the best time to catch people
at home and i had a script that i
created
and i would call people
and say hey it's michelle from state
farm insurance
you know i can't remember something
about lowering your you know car
insurance or
home insurance by blah blah blah i'd
love to schedule a time for you to talk
to the agent does wednesday at one
o'clock work
you know and i literally was setting up
so many appointments
and passing it off to the agents um to
where like i was outselling
the people who were paid full time to
sell
wow and um and so it's crazy right
and why was that was it because was it
because your script was better because
you were more enthusiastic why do you
think you're out selling them
that's a great question michael i think
for a couple
reasons let me just i really believe
that i'm the best
at what i do and nobody does what i do
better than me i've always believed that
even at a very young age
so having that confidence brings a level
of energy
to any conversation to any
um situation to any circumstance right
um on top of that i'm pretty strategic
even back then like i was taught
i was taught how to script and so once i
learned specific words and ways and
things to say things
you know you just get really good at you
know using
keywords and power words and action
words
um and then asking the right questions
so
um i was trained well i believe i'm the
best
and i'm intentionally strategic about
how i did things so even at that young
age you know i was just
you know what i mean they i intentional
and strategic that that is not something
very common to most 15 year olds
and and i think that that's that's
really cool so so you learn it you learn
about
this idea that you know by being
intentional strategic confident
you get very very far how do you then
translate that for the rest of your
career
so so that confidence piece just
continued to grow because
as you know michael once you
once you can you continue to reassure
yourself or you continue to get all
these little
buy-ins and wins reaffirming that like
you know like dang okay i really am the
best you know i'm really good
your confidence begins to grow and it
continues to grow
so from then you know when i went to
college i was in i was in college i had
sales internships
in college right um in in in marketing
and advertising but i was still working
in the summers and on breaks at this
agency
so i was continuing to hone my skills
because i was working for the
best sale i was working for the best
state farm agent
in florida and she was one of the tops
in the in the nation
so i was getting the best training um
and so i was taking all of these little
tidbits that i've learned about
sales leadership into everything i do to
answer your question
um so when i got my internships
as a college student i was taking
everything i learned from her
into you know into that my first job
out of college was with ferguson
enterprises and it was a sales job
and i wanted to go into advertising but
the in the the outside when you graduate
from college as an advertising major
you get like 16 000 a year i mean like
it's
it's no money at all and i was like i
can't
yeah it was like it's insane it was you
know and this was
a few years ago i won't say how many
this is a few years back right
um but you don't make a lot of money
coming out as an advertising or
journalism major and i just didn't want
to
not be paid so i was like forget this
and i went directly into sales
and from there again i worked for the
the largest wholesaling
wholesaler plumbing wholesaler in the
world
and i got the best training and
i was good at it because i was
intentional
i aligned myself with the right people
and i allowed myself to be trained
and so again all of these tidbits i got
from the state farm agent
i took to that and then all the things i
learned
as a salesperson at ferguson enterprises
i took to my next job so it's this
constant building
and taking you know life really is a
journey
and what we have to remember is that
we if you know where you want to go
you're intentional about how you get
there and you realize that
every single step is preparation
for the end or whatever that looks like
every single step if you do it right
right
right um and so i i knew at the time as
a salesperson
the the thing you want to do do you know
this like as a sales person like the
end-all be-all job as a salesperson is
like
medical device sales or biotech sales
that's where you make the most money
yeah wow i actually didn't know that
yeah so like for me as a sales person i
was in business to business sales
but i wanted to be medical device rep
biotech
because i knew at the time that was
where the money was
and so i was intentional about placing
myself there in order for me to get into
biotech or med device
i had to be a pharmaceutical sales rep
in order to be a pharmaceutical sales
rep
i had to get business to
sales so again this intention this focus
the strategic play so you ask the
question how did i take this
into my journey into my these are all
the things
i learned to take to be strategic so
i got business to business sales
experience i was great at it won all
kinds of awards
got a job in pharmaceutical sales and
then when i got to pharmaceutical sales
i realized that in medical device sales
they didn't necessarily want
pharmaceutical sales reps because they
thought they couldn't really sell
because all you're doing is dropping off
drugs and
and so uh then i had to prove that i can
really sell
like i'm not just dropping off drugs i'm
a salesperson at heart
and i landed myself in medical device
sales
knowing that eventually i would be
running my own business because that was
always the goal
to start my own business right when when
did that goal begin
this idea of running your own business
and because one of the things one of the
things that i'm picking up here is this
idea of intentionality and strategically
strategic placement and training
understanding that every
pit stop along the ways of preparation
for sort of
this this big milestone so now i
understand that you know you've had this
vision to run your own business all
along really and those were just
stepping stones for you that's exactly
right
um when i was a kid i was raised my mom
raised me and two of my sisters or two
sisters
and uh and my mom
was a business owner i saw her
work corporately
but i also remember when
she completely cut ties working for
someone else
and she started her own business now her
business
did i learned this i learned everything
from my mom and business and raising
kids all that i get it from my mom
but she had you know what we now call a
side hustle
yeah and so running i remember watching
her as a child
run her own business while she worked
two jobs for someone else so she's
building her empire slowly but steadily
as she's continuing to be able to pay
the bills
for her children and watching her
do that i knew at a very young age i was
destined to become an entrepreneur and
not just be an entrepreneur solopreneur
but to build a business to scale a
business to grow
an empire i knew that that was what i
was supposed to do because
i watched my mom do it um
my father who wasn't in the picture much
but
he was he owned his own business my
grandmother
on my mom's side had her own business my
grandfather on my mom's side i had his
own
my grandfather on my dad's side like
everybody
entrepreneurship is in the dna right
and the interesting thing about dna is
that dna is going to do what it's going
to do
we don't have a lot of control over it
right
right and i it sounds to me that one of
the things that you don't have control
much is
over that passion over this passion for
autonomy
passion for resilience that grit seeing
you know failure after failure but the
attitude of
persevering and being intentional being
strategic
and through these milestones and to the
end
reaching the light right that sounds to
me something that's completely inspiring
growing up
yeah it is and i think we have to
remember that
failure i was just i was interviewed
yesterday and i was asked this question
failure doesn't mean you failed failure
gives us an opportunity
to to get it right right
and i can think of time specifically in
business where i felt like i failed
right i um
i remember even in the magazine i have a
magazine in my media company
and there were times when um i was the
only sales person like right now even
i'm the only sales person because it's
hard to find
good sales people and you're carrying a
bag
as a ceo with 13 employees
and you're out there selling your
company
and when the sales aren't hitting
sometimes uh when people aren't
paying their bills when covet happens
and you've got
you know um 100 150 200 000
in ar and you have to pay employees
and pay yourself you kind of feel like a
failure
right right right
um but i i call it god
i don't know what other people might
call it something different but
god has a way of reminding me that i was
built for this because
for every person that doesn't pay on
time
somebody else sends a check out of
nowhere
and i'm like okay i'm with you okay i
got it right
for every deal that doesn't close that i
think
should close three more come out of
nowhere
right like that literally happens or i
go into a deal just happened a few weeks
ago and i'm thinking like this is it i'm
closing this
this is done this is a 100 000 contract
we're good
and they're like nope and i'm like oh
god i suck
but then like literally i walk out you
know and i'm driving and i get a call
of course from someone who's like hey
listen i've been watching your magazine
for three years
i called you three years ago i couldn't
afford it
i can now afford it and i want a
two-page spread
and a back cover for 36 months
how do i get started what do i do and
i'm like
there you go again right i think
that's like what you're describing here
right i think what you're describing
here you know from what i said is a lot
of people can make the very
easy mistake of of attaching those two
events
and saying you know if i failed in
in that then then that's an indication
of of my worth
and the fact that i you know and and
then i that that is like an indication
of everything but then
but they really are not connected right
because for every you know nine failures
you could get one success
and and i think that what you're
describing here is a perfect example
where that single event
doesn't cannot be extrapolated most
often to
to describe you know the overall
structure
and those events aren't connected
necessarily there could be a greater
force maybe but
but they are not connected what's
connect what's connecting is that
your business has a lot of value and you
as an entrepreneur has to have to
understand that
every single occurrence is independent
of other occurrences and you just have
to persevere
until you find them right michael let me
tell you something you're absolutely
right and i'm going to say this to you
and i'm going to say it to your viewing
audience
you cannot live life by circumstances
circumstances will fail you they will
they will
erode your confidence they will
destroy everything you've built
circumstances are not
how you live if you live your business
professionally
or personally by circumstance you will
likely fail and i don't mean fail like
in a good way
because you'll never be able to win
you'll never see the winds
and i tell people often when you have a
win
no matter how small or how large you
have to
live in that wind
right celebrate just you have to
celebrate it
right i just had a team meeting
yesterday
and um we just signed a new uh agreement
we're taking our show
um we're adding another network to our
to our tv show
or adding our tv show to another network
and um
and you know that's a huge win we just
it was a
that's a big deal like big deal and like
literally deal on paper right
and my team will you know we talked
about and then we're like moving on to
the next and we're going and i was like
wait a minute no no
like we need to celebrate this
like this is a this is a big deal they
came after
us they wanted us because on the flip
side michael
if we were to get cancelled by some
network
we'd be devastated and you'd live in
that
right right you'd live in that
so we have to like really really
accept and live in the the winds
i hear people say sometimes well i never
get too low i never get too high
and i get that but i feel like you got
to get high
because life will life will take you
down if you let it
exactly what i mean a hundred percent
100 and i think that
those words are so so important for me
for for my friends that are
watching this so thank you for sharing
we just have a few minutes left 20
minutes go by way too quickly but
michelle tell me a little bit about your
book and
we complete we didn't even talk about an
entire subject that i wanted to which
which is the idea of parenting and
entrepreneurship together not something
that i have any experience myself
whatsoever but
but you do and you you wrote about it as
well not
yet not yet hopefully my girlfriend is
not watching this for the time being
and not yet but michelle tell me a
little bit about your book and
and about your experience and some of
the key insights that you've gained from
them
yeah so the book really was built around
teaching people how to parent
intentionally
and from an entrepreneurship uh focus
this is important because when you have
kids
and you're running your own business it
opens up a lot of doors
because it allows flexibility and
malleability and schedule
but it also closes a lot of doors
because you end up
working a lot right you end up working
often and your kids see that so
part of the reason i wrote the book is
because i wanted people to see that
you know even as an entrepreneur you can
still be very present
and very aware and very intentional
about how you parent
your kids and the there are two
benefactors in this
it's your kids but it's also you
right right um and so i talk a lot in
the book
about um different different situations
i pose in the book where
it works right so my first tenet is obey
immediately and happily
and i got that from a head mistress at
the school
that we were touring some years back
from one of my kids i have four boys
and uh and she was like listen we teach
all of our
kids to obey immediately and happily
because if they don't listen to us
they you we can't train them for the
outside world how do you train someone
that won't listen to you
right right and so even now
michael my kids they mock me now
sometimes but
i'll be like how do we obey and they're
like immediately and happily you know
i'm like okay
let's get to it i'm missing the
immediate and happily happy piece of
this right
um but my kids they know this stuff i
can't train you
if you don't if you don't listen to me
right
um no and i'm sure that it's it's a
beautiful line of both
the the obedience but this what i'm
hearing from is
it's not just the obedience but it's the
openness because really what does it
mean happily
it means to be open-minded while doing
something right
uh you know i served in the military for
a few years here and
and this concept of obedience
immediately
that that makes perfect sense especially
you know in in dangerous circumstances
where
you know your life experience your life
experience
is much greater than theirs and is first
it's is
comply and now but being open-minded
while doing so
allows you to actually understand why
why does that make sense
and and and really and understand it
internally so that you can exercise that
independent thought process yourself
later on right
i love what you just said i'm actually
going to take that
and steal it and i promise i'll give you
your credit for it michael
but i'm going to take that because
you're right
when people hear happily they think that
the kids are skipping off like yay i'm
going to clean my room i can't wait
and it's not that no it's the fact that
you're not going to push back right
it's that you're not going to be
resistant it's the fact that you're
going to be
open-minded to the fact that you need to
do what i tell you to do
and and i love this there's a situation
that happened and i talk about this in
the book from a danger perspective i
love that you said that um where we were
we've been places
sometimes and i and i tell my kids get
in the car
right and they're like oh they're just
like why do i need to get get in the car
you know you don't get in the car we get
car checked
we get you know whatever because you
don't listen so
now i can't even do my job as a parent i
can't even
protect you because you're not listening
to me
and that happens we see these examples
all the time i mean i've had it i mean
we've never been carjacked but
i've had examples where i've told my get
in the car
get in the car and i'm like literally
snatching them get in the car like
there's a weird guy
walking around here i don't know what
he's doing like get in the car
you know um but we it's our job
and michael you're learning this when
you have kids
but it's our job to send our children
back in as good or better condition
than we got them 100 that's our job
100 yeah michelle
it's uh we can go on for hours i feel
like we just opened up a pandora's box
and i think that what i'll have to do is
i'm gonna have to first read the book
and i'm gonna have to invite you to
another podcast because i have a i have
about 20 more questions than what i've
started with
so thank you for that whatever you don't
tell everybody that you tell everyone
that you're just no no
no no no no no i genuinely
very very much enjoyed this and i think
that the insights are bringing to the
table
with first you know on the business side
the intentionality and strategic
thinking
and that mindset the training mindset as
a stepping stones until
reaching that that great that great
objective i think that's
that's exactly what how i am trying to
to live you know my professional career
your insights into this idea of
parenting with entrepreneurship
and and the your own inspiration growing
up and
and that just the first lesson that you
got to share with me i i just can't wait
to read about
those other lessons but for now michelle
i have the final question for you
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
three words um
giving
strategic slash intentional can i make
that the same word
a hundred percent and um
and joyful i love it michelle
thank you very very much i'll see you in
atlanta georgia when i'm there
and until then stay safe and stay
healthy
listen thank you so much for having me
and if anyone wants to follow me you can
i'm at michelle taylor willis on just
about everything
wonderful thank you very very much take
care
you